hey
how many unreleased tk how many
unreleased greedo songs are still in the
cut
if i told you how many
i knew i knew it because he dude 1400
songs today
so cool yo i feel like you got to grab
like 10 of them and do the
the the greato draco project yeah that'd
be big bro
is that something that you guys have
have brainstormed about doing like a
project where you don't agree don't do
that before i can't in jail yeah
so that's something that's already in
the in the air pretty much
and you got 1400 songs to choose from
so if he's got 1400 and you just crank
the album out in five days
yeah how many how many songs do you got
we haven't heard
well a lot i mean i wrote 209 songs in
jail
so like i got a lot of yeah
i got a lot every single song that was
on my mixtape i wrote in jail
every single one so you know most people
can't write
all you had to do was come out and get
the beats and just go straight in and
lay them down
i just that's why i tested it out with
this mixtape and apparently people like
everything that i wrote in jail because
when i wrote in jail i visualized it
as if i was on the streets so you can't
write if you in jail nobody want to hear
that all day people talk about jail and
i don't want to hear and i was in jail
so